let's go to brian from gainesville
georgia today
hi david glad you're doing well thank
you
so it seems like we're on the verge of
more
mass hospitalizations from this delta
variance
we may be we may be georgia
especially here in georgia so i i guess
my question
is uh since vaccinated people
for the most part have largely kind of
returned to
mostly return to normal we're starting
to go into movie theaters now
even um what
i hate to even suggest this but should
at some point
hospitals consider prioritizing
for example when somebody gets into a
really bad car accident and they need
instant medical attention versus
somebody who's unvaccinated and
needs medical attention i i just i just
i feel like that
because of the wave of uh the the new
coronavirus wave that's coming through
that the hospitals are just going to get
possibly even more overwhelmed than
when we first went into lockdown and i
don't think it'll get
that bad because there are a lot of
people vaccinated
who are very unlikely to get the virus
and if they do they're very unlikely to
be symptomatic
and if they are they're very unlikely to
be hospitalized so
i think it's not going to get that bad i
do think it's going to get bad
particularly among the unvaccinated
population but what you're suggesting is
complicated because
so like what's on the fundamental of
what you're saying correct me if i'm
wrong is
not getting vaccinated is an
irresponsible action so therefore if you
need medical attention as a result of
that
you should be lower priority more or
less that's what you're saying right
that's what i'm i i don't
i don't know if that's what should be
done i'm just
no no i'm going to get to where should
hospitals consider that right as an
option
i don't i don't think so and the reason
why
is we know riding a motorcycle
is really dangerous compared to driving
in a car would we say
people in motorcycle accidents should be
deprioritized from car accidents
no no people wouldn't say that no we
know that
smoking is a self-destructive and and
negative to your health activity
does that mean if you smoke and you go
and you have i don't know a pulmonary
embolism i don't even know if smoking
can cause that but some lung thing
acute you go to the emergency room and
they go sorry
the kid who broke his ankle gets
priority
because the the kid doesn't smoke the
kid was just playing basketball
it just it just would you know hospitals
have a duty to treat and they have
triage protocols and i just i know what
you're saying which is
it's such an easy thing you just go get
vaccinated you reduce the chances of
clogging up the medical system
i just don't think in practice it's
gonna it's really something that can be
done
i see i see and i think i think you're
right i don't
i don't think it will get that bad but
i'm also looking at this from this
perspective of like for example when we
went into lockdown
yep uh a lot of us stayed home we were
off the roads
uh we uh didn't uh you know that
helped with uh that helped to some
extent with
uh with car crashes yeah uh which
like so i'm a traffic engineer for
example so i see
uh i have seen throughout this year the
uh
even though there were fewer cars on the
road uh
there was an increase in uh there was an
increase particularly in deaths
yeah per capita per capita car accident
death yeah
yes indeed uh so i noticed that and i
think some of that is possibly due to
you know okay there's fewer people on
the road so people feel more comfortable
driving at higher speeds
and that's when those collisions take
place absolutely
that's the that's the theory yeah i mean
it's the same thing like
if you were driving irresponsibly fast
so we're going to treat the person with
the headache first it's like it just
doesn't work that way that's not the way
our system works
indeed but a very very important topic
and i appreciate you bringing it up
thank you david all right thank you very
much all right guys
excellent topics today for the most part
that does it for calls today
we're going to take a quick break we'll
be back with more show today
and we will take calls again fear not